[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg
guten abend und danke schon jetzt für
ihr interesse
norbert lehmann ist auch dabei für den
sport zwei milram tor von mir und das
sind unsere themen heute schlamm
müllberge stehendes wasser wegen einer
gefährlichen mischung drohen den
betroffenen in den flutgebieten jetzt
auch noch krankheiten zankapfel nord
stream 2 in den usa der ukraine und
anderswo hagelt es kritik an der
einigung zwischen washington und berlin
dumm gelaufen einen tag vor der
eröffnungsfeier starten die deutschen
fußballer mit einer schlappe gegen
brasilien in ihr olympisches turnier
auch mehr als eine woche nach der
flutkatastrophe ist noch unklar wie
viele menschen dabei ums leben gekommen
sind 175 leichen wurden bislang geborgen
viele sind noch nicht identifiziert mehr
als 150 menschen werden immer noch
vermisst
in den zerstörten ortschaften häufen
sich trümmer und tonnenweise müll eine
unheilvolle kombination bei den
sommertemperaturen
denn die gefahr von krankheiten durch
erreger oder gäste nimmt zu zumal es
kaum fließendes wasser gibt thomas
münten berichtet aus bad münstereifel
und erftstadt blättern in erftstadt
lassen dürfen die anwohner erst seit
heute wieder in ihre häuser
dort hat das wasser eine ganze woche
gestanden hier ist die hygienische
situation angespannt ist natürlich hier
ein problem sauberes trinkwasser an die
bevölkerung zu bekommen dass sie sich
halt waschen können sodass dann
keinerlei eigenes trinkwasser oder
sonstige sachen dann benutzt werden so
dass dann keine krankheiten über mikro
bakterien oder sowas an die leute halt
geben bad münstereifel der schlamm
stinkt nach öl darüber eine staubwolke
wo es bereits trocken ist auch heute
wird geräumt geschippt und entsorgt das
alles ohne sauberes wasser im stadtkern
kein strom keine kanalisation hygiene
spielt momentan keine rolle
moment funktioniere handwerker
funktioniert und weiter weiter weiter
wir wollen ja wieder unter die leute wir
wollen da wieder dass das waren die die
geschäfte wieder öffnen können
hier sind so viele leute die hilfe
brauchen das verschiebt sich in den
prioritäten vor 14 tagen jetzt ja noch
mehrere hohe gefährt ich habe auf man
muss jetzt machen tun
rund um den stadtkern wurde den
sportteilen und firmengebäuden hygiene
möglichkeiten geschaffen aber lange kann
das so nicht gehen nur darum kümmern
geht auch noch nicht wir müssen erstmal
schauen am wochenende ist wieder regen
angekündigt dass wir da die erft frei
bekommen die ist zwar in ihrem bett
wieder aber nicht tief genug weil da
noch schutt und alles drin ist das ist
erstmal priorität einzig muss frei
gemacht werden
da liegt noch vieles drin und dazu kommt
dass enorme müllproblem
die bezirksregierung köln sucht
inzwischen per internet bundesweit
transport und lagermöglichkeiten um die
orte so schnell wie möglich frei zu
bekommen wie viel in den
hochwassergebieten wieder aufgebaut
werden muss lassen heute diese zahlen
aus rheinland-pfalz erahnen 62 brücken
wurden dort zerstört 13 beschädigt
außerdem sind 19 kindertagesstätten
stark beschädigt oder komplett kaputt
und 14 schulen und auch im für die
region so wichtigen weinbau hat die flut
ihre spuren hinterlassen
angela app hat und botticelli bis zum
zweiten stock reichte das wasser
vergangene woche im weingut von familie
gilles seit drei generationen gibt es
den betrieb in dernau marienthal direkt
an der weinkeller die abfüllanlagen
alles ist zerstört
wir können den wein vielleicht noch
ernten die trauben draußen
die hängen ja noch aber wir haben nichts
um sie zu verarbeiten nichts um sie zu
ernten nichts um den wein in die flasche
zu bringen gar nicht wie viele andere
winzerinnen und winzer an der ahr rissen
die geht es noch nicht ob sie aus
eigener kraft weitermachen können ohne
finanzielle unterstützung wird es wohl
nicht gehen das wäre super schade wenn
das so eine katastrophe diese familien
beim mieter die in traditionsreicher
weise immer weiter geführt werden nicht
überleben
albert schmitz ist landwirt aus
nordrhein westfalen seit vergangener
woche hilft der anderen bauern winzern
und vielen anderen menschen im rheinland
pfälzischen paartal die ersten tage
haben wir nur rettungswege frei
geschoben mit anderer maschinerie
straßen freigeräumt dass die
rettungskräfte auffahren konnten in
erster linie und den leuten halt auch
den schock den die aus den häusern
rausgeholt haben versucht zu verladen
und wegzufahren seine fahrzeuge seien
dabei mehrfach beschädigt worden sagt
schmitz er wünscht sich staatliche
finanzielle hilfe nicht für seine arbeit
sondern für reparaturen die die helfen
die die hilfe brauchen sie alle hoffen
auf weitere unterstützung von außen
ja es ist weiter viel hilfe nötig im
katastrophengebiet und es ist schon
einiges zusammen gekommen
bei der zdf spendenaktion sind es fast
34 millionen euro
das aktionsbündnis katastrophenhilfe hat
ja gezielt ein spendenkonto eingerichtet
die iban lautet de 65 104 106 100 104
106 100 stichwort hochwasser weitere
informationen finden sie unter spenden
punkt zdf.de und im zdf text auf seite 8
190 die katastrophe zieht nicht nur
helfende an
seit tagen waren die polizei vor
gerüchten und falschmeldungen
die im katastrophengebiet über
lautsprecher verbreitet werden zudem
würden sich offenbar leute aus der
querdenker szene und rechtsextremisten
als kümmerer vor ort anbieten
andreas christian ott und pablo sie lala
hier haben
details auf den ersten blick ein ganz
normales polizeifahrzeug doch der
kleinbus mit der aufschrift friedens
fahrzeug stiftet vor allem eins
verwirrung im hochwassergebiet von bad
neuenahr ahrweiler ist er unterwegs und
soll per lautsprecherdurchsage
verbreitet haben alle hilfskräfte aus
der region seien abgezogen worden
die bundeswehr stellt klar im
hochwassergebiet streuen die sogenannten
friedens fahrzeuge fehlinformationen das
entspricht nicht der wahrheit alle
kräfte sind weiter in vollem umfang vor
ort die polizei sieht auch raichs bürger
und querdenker hinter der aktion
es ist ein konglomerat aus verschiedenen
menschen und wir haben auch die
erkenntnis dass sich unter diesen
menschen die der gruppe zu gehören
personen der sogenannten reichspost
beziehungsweise der querdenker szene bis
hin
sie hatten tagelang in dieser
grundschule ihr hauptquartier
koordinierten von hier aus hilfsaktionen
betreuten kinder von flutopfern und
inszenierten sich in videos als helfer
die einspringen wo der start ihrer
meinung nach versagt
bis gestern am abend hat die polizei die
einrichtung geschlossen
bei den menschen vor ort gemischte
reaktionen
ich finde das ganz apathisch dass sowas
ausgenutzt wird nicht bei allen stößt
die aktion der selbsternannten helfer
auf ablehnung und juristisch hat die
polizei gegen sie keine handhabe
das hochwasser war auch eines der themen
von angela merkel in ihrer wohl letzten
sommer pressekonferenz heute das ganze
war aber auch eine art bilanz am ende
ihrer 16 jährigen amtszeit als
bundeskanzlerin klaus brodbeck war für
uns in berlin dabei weitermachen wie
immer bis zum schluss auch dieses mal
merkel freundlich geschäftsmäßig es geht
um die sache
beispiel die flut und ihre folgen
wir werden zur behebung dieser schäden
einen langen atem brauchen deshalb ist
die bundesregierung natürlich auch in
kontakt mit den ländern insbesondere mit
den betroffenen ländern um aufbauhilfe
zu planen und natürlich auch gemeinsam
zu finanzieren beispiel pandemie merkel
wirbt eindringlich für die impfung gegen
korona eine impfung schützt nicht nur
gut vor schwerer krankheit und schmerz
sondern auch vor dem beschränkende
maßnahmen unseres alltags beispiel
klimawandel in ihrer amtszeit wurden
erneuerbare energien ausgebaut
emissionen gesenkt doch beides nicht
genug gemessen an dem ziel deutlich
unter zwei grad oder möglichst nahen 15
grad celsius anstieg ist nicht
ausreichend viel passiert und deshalb
muss das tempo angezogen werden fragen
zum abschied vom amt weicht merkel aus
beispiel wo wird sie seien am abend der
wahl habe ich mir jetzt noch keine
gedanken gemacht aber ich werde schon
verbindung zu der partei haben die
ehrenmitglied ich bin nicht mehr so nahe
steht die steht mir auch sie steht mir
nahe und ich bin ihr mitglied merkels 29
sste auftritt vor der
bundespressekonferenz der letzte vor
einer politischen sommerpause womöglich
ihr nicht die letzte überhaupt
die kanzlerin verteidigte auch die
umstrittene einigung mit den usa im
streit um die gas pipeline nord stream 2
das projekt kann jetzt fertiggestellt
werden und noch mehr gas direkt von
sankt petersburg nach mecklenburg
vorpommern fließen die ukraine bisher
transit land bleibt dann außen vor
für kiew ist die pipeline eine doppelte
bedrohung der transport von russischem
gas war nicht nur eine wichtige
einnahmequelle sondern auch eine
lebensversicherung gegen aggressionen
aus moskau
andreas kuhnert es gibt kaum einen in
washington der die einigung zur nord
stream 2 für einen sieg hält im kongress
sprechen beide parteien von einer
niederlage der usa
und nicht mal der präsident versucht wie
ein sieger zu klingen
[Musik]
nord stream ist zu 99 prozent fertig
einen stopp herbeizuführen war nicht
möglich aber wenn russland der ukraine
oder anderen ländern absichtlich
schmerzen zufügt hat deutschland
zugesagt zu reagieren
deutschland hat zugesagt der ukraine zu
helfen ihre energieversorgung zu sichern
zb klimafreundliche wasserstoff projekte
zu fördern und trotzdem den russischen
gastransit mit verhandlungen zu
verlängern
denn die ukraine fühlt sich angreifbar
sobald russland nicht mehr auf seine
dortigen gasleitungen angewiesen ist
leider können die vorschläge diese
sicherheitslücke zu schließen nicht als
ausreichend angesehen werden schreiben
die außenminister der ukraine und polens
heute in einem gemeinsamen statement
kanzlerin merkel erklärt sie verstehe
die sorgen aber völlig wehrlos sei man
nicht dann haben wir natürlich auch die
möglichkeit von der ich nicht gebrauch
machen möchte aber die wehr immer haben
im zusammenhang der krim oder mit den
jetzt und lugansk auch die möglichkeit
sanktionen zu machen also wir sind ja
nicht ohne jedes mittel etwas zu tun
nach zehn jahren streit fehlt nord
stream 2 nichts mehr zur fertigstellung
außer ein paar wenigen rohren und vier
bis fünf wochen zeit
fangen wir unseren korrespondenten in
washington benjamin daniel warum lenkt
der us präsident in diesem streit ein
er lenkt er ein weil er abgewogen hat
und aus seiner sicht am ende die
vorteile für die usa überwiegen in der
tat gibt es seit langem kritik gegen das
projekt und zwar ist beiden politischen
lagern das bekommt schrauben ja auch
gerade sehr stark zu spüren
und er ist ja auch selbst der auffassung
dass das projekt für europa und für
deutschland bedeutet dass man da in eine
größere abhängigkeit von russland gerät
und dass das vor allem auch die
transitländer wie die ukraine durchaus
dass es den transitländern schaden
könnte
gleichwohl betont er immer wieder dass
er glaube die pipeline
ohnehin fast fertig gestellt und das
egal welche maßnahmen ergriffen hätte
die inbetriebnahme nicht mehr verhindert
hätte hätte verhindern können und
außerdem nach den jahren unter trump ist
es ihm auch daran gelegen dass das
zerrüttete verhältnis zu deutschland
immer in einem der wichtigsten
bündnispartner wieder neu erstarken kann
und ganz konkret gibt es noch eine
strategische komponente
er wird natürlich auch auf die volle
unterstützung der bundesregierung zählen
wenn es darum geht um seine politischen
forderungen der zukunft zb beim thema
klimawandel
zum beispiel wenn es darum geht wie man
auf politische auf militärische
provokationen reagiert oder wenn es
darum geht um eine gemeinsame haltung
gegenüber menschenrechtsverletzungen
durch china oder russland dankeschön
live aus washington war dass benjamin
daniel schmerz und trauer aber auch
quälende fragen sie bestimmen diesen 22
juli in norwegen vor genau zehn jahren
hatte ein rechtsextremist erst im osloer
regierungsviertel eine autobombe
gezündet dann erschoss er auf der insel
utoya wahllos jugendliche eines
zeltlagers der sozialdemokraten
insgesamt starben 77 menschen der täter
sitzt hinter gittern der hass aber sei
nicht gestoppt worden sagte heute eine
überlebende
rené hebestreit in oslos
regierungsviertel gedenken sie der toten
der anschläge vom 22
juli 2011 hier vor bei der explosion von
einer tonne sprengstoff acht menschen
starben
erinnert ministerpräsidentin soll werk
daran dass in norwegen rechtsextremes
gedankengut bis heute nicht überwunden
ist
wir wissen dass viele überlebende von
ihr bedroht werden das ist inakzeptabel
es zeigt das wie rassismus hass und
extremismus weiter bekämpfen müssen
astrid hoer ist eine von denen die auf
dem mörder entkommen konnten immer
wieder ist sie auf die insel
zurückgekehrt wo sie als 16-jährige mit
vielen anderen um ihr leben rannten wo
sie alle verzweifelt unter den klippen
deckung suchten als wir unten ankommen
gucken wir uns unter einem felsvorsprung
doch die 10 die am ende der schlange
stehen werden alle erschossen
[Musik]
anders breivik wurde zur höchststrafe
von 21 jahren mit anschließender
sicherungsverwahrung verurteilt
inzwischen hat er sich in einem brief an
oslos heutige vize bürgermeisterin vom
rechtsextremismus losgesagt und um eine
begnadigung nach der regulären haftzeit
gebeten von entschuldigung aber keine
spur
und so hat sie die er vor zehn jahren
auf die töten wollte ihm öffentlich eine
deutliche absage erteilt du hast mich
fürs leben verletzt mich fürs leben
gezeichnet ich habe freunde verloren
weil du dafür gesorgt hast heute stehen
die opfer im mittelpunkt und die
forderung rassismus zu bekämpfen
schauen wir jetzt auf die korona zahlen
die steigen hierzulande langsam aber
stetig in tourismus hochburgen wie
spanien oder griechenland liegen sie
deutlich höher so dass viele unsicher
sind ob sie überhaupt groß verreisen
sollen oder doch lieber urlaub zu hause
machen entsprechend gut besucht sind die
deutschen feriengebiete fabian köhler
norderney hauptstrand bei 20 grad und
angenehmen wassertemperaturen gut
besucht rund 17.000 gäste verbringen
aktuell hier ihren urlaub die inzidenz
liegt bei 0
das gibt sicherheit entschieden
damit werden damit wir sicher sind dass
wir noch wegkommen und nicht irgendwie
in quarantäne dann kommen wenn man
gehen wir haben vor kroner immer im
ausland urlaub gemacht und sind jetzt zu
deutschland urlaub an geworden hans
vollmer vermietet 350 wohnungen auf der
ostfriesischen insel im zweiten corona
sommer eine beliebte unterkunfts form 70
prozent der übernachtung auf den
ostfriesischen inseln und an der küste
werden in ferienwohnungen getätigt die
einen urlaub mit ferienwohnungen den
kann man fast kontaktlos abwickeln
das hundertprozentig corona sicher von
der see bis an die berge die deutschen
ferienregionen sind gut gebucht doch
auch im ausland rund um das mittelmeer
haben die buchungen wieder stark
angezogen reisende buchen aber sehr
kurzfristig oft wenige tage vor abflug
das liegt natürlich auch daran dass man
ganz genau sicher gehen will dass seine
destinationen auch vernünftig bereits
bei ist dass die sicherheitskonzepte
stimmen die nächsten wochen werden
zeigen wie corona sicher der urlaub im
inland und ausland war und ob die
zurückgewonnene normalität bleibt und
jetzt zu olympia und der frage wer
morgen bei der eröffnungsfeier die
deutsche fahne tragen darauf ja sind
beachvolleyballerin laura ludwig und
wasserspringer patrick hausding die die
wahl gewonnen haben abgestimmt hatten ja
sportler und fans erstmals gibt es bei
der eröffnungsfeier gemischte
fahnenträger paare ein signal für mehr
geschlechtergleichheit das probetragen
der fahne hat schon mal geklappt laura
ludwig und patrick hausding sind damit
bestens gerüstet für ihren besonderen
moment wenn alle vier fünf jahre dort
nur einer bzw dieses jahr das erste mal
zwei leute für ausgewählt werden dann
ist das eine riesen ehre für beide ist
es die vierte olympia-teilnahme
beachvolleyballerin ludwig gewand 2016
in rio gold wasserspringer hausding
holte bronze
die aufgabenverteilung morgen scheint
bereits festzustehen
einziger wermutstropfen wegen corona
wird das stadion morgen in tokio nahezu
leer sein und eine der beachvolleyball
gegnerin von laura ludwig ist übrigens
positiv auf corona getestet worden
insgesamt gab es bisher 87 fälle im
umfeld
spiele und in tokio selbst steigen die
neuinfektionen weiter stark an auf fast
2000 bin eines tages olympia fehlstart
für die deutschen fußballer das team von
dfb trainer stefan kunst verlor gegen
den olympiasieger von 2000 16 brasilien
mit 2 zu viel zu stark die brasilianer
zu entschlossen ihr star richardsson
drei tore in einer halbzeit hattrick für
den profi vom fc everton marktwert 55
millionen real madrid holt gerade um ihn
deutscher florian müller oft allein
einem brasilianischen angreifer
gegenüber und trotz der gegentore bester
mann ein gehaltener elfmeter gegen kuhn
ja einziger lichtblick der ersten
halbzeit nahm ihm amiris 1 zu 3
unverhofft und ermutigend kurz danach
aber gelb-rot für kapitän arnold nach
foul an dani alves und doch ließ sache
noch einmal hoffen bis leverkusens
paulinho in der nachspielzeit traf und
trainer kunst am ende 1 15 feldspieler
eingesetzt hatte vielleicht klappt's ja
am sonntag gegen saudi arabien wenn wir
sie morgen gibt's nochmal oft sonne und
nur wenig regen zum samstag drohen dann
gewitter wo und wie heftig das erzählt
gleich katja hornuf christian sievers
freut sich auf sie im heute journal um
viertel vor zehn und wir freuen uns wenn
sie morgen wieder dabei sind alles gute
ihn auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten abend die luft am mittelmeer ist
feucht und sehr warm und so entwickelten
sich hier auf der alpensüdseite aber
auch an der ligurischen küste und über
dem appell ihn heute einige gewitter
über norddeutschland zogen wieder wolken
hinweg die sich am nachmittag aber mehr
und mehr auflösten und klaren himmel den
gibt es jetzt auch in der nacht in
süddeutschland einzig aus den alben
heraus sind klitzekleine regenschauer
nicht völlig ausgeschlossen
die temperaturen dazu sinken auf werte
zwischen 15 und 9 grad und steigen
morgen an der küste auf 20 21 grad sonst
werden 22 bis 25 und im süden und
südwesten 27 bis 30 grad erreicht
morgen wird nochmal ein sonniger tag nur
in norddeutschland sind die wolken etwas
dichter und bringen wieder hier und da
ein ganz kleine paar spritzer regen mit
sonst aber strahlt die sonne das wird
sich dann aber am samstag ändern da
kommt kräftige gewitter von westen heran
das können unwetter seien also gewitter
die mit hagel platzregen und sturmböen
verbunden sind örtlich können so 20 bis
40 liter regen pro quadratmeter
zusammenkommen
in der nacht zu sonntag ziehen diese
gewitter weiter nach osten und gewittrig
geht es dann in der neuen woche auch
noch weiter guten abend